welcome to my snapchat story where I use
snapchat to explain snapchat on the left
hand side of this video you'll see my
snaps snaps our photos are up to ten
second videos on the right hand side
you'll see how we made them the app
sounds easy to use right it's not
seriously it's so easy you just add
photos and videos to your story and then
it disappear after 24 hours mom
easy if you know how to decipher
hieroglyphics and have an impeccable
sense of navigating confusing menus
seriously who designed this icon but
it's time to stop complaining you need
to know what's going on here your kids
are here the White House is here the
presidential candidates and celebrities
first things first you're gonna want
friends tap that little snapchat ghost
icon or you can add friends by username
or it can scan your address book but all
the cool kids use snap codes this is my
snap code friends add each other by
pointing the camera at the snap code and
holding down swipe to the left of the
main screen and you'll see your friends
stories stories are a string of snaps
that are taken over the last 24 hours
just tap on a story and keep tapping and
tapping and tapping and tapping and
tapping and tapping and tapping and
tapping the real skill comes in posting
your snaps you want to find interesting
or fun things in your life and just be
you
okay maybe you don't really have to be
here
taking photos is easy just one tap
videos a little bit trickier you have to
hold down on the button and you only
have a 10 seconds for your clip you want
to change to the front-facing camera
DoubleTap avoid horizontal photos and
videos though the Apple and adjust for
it and nobody wants to turn their screen
to watch your snap then it's all about
adding fun extras text captions are my
favorite DoubleTap the text button to
get the bolder font then you want to use
the pen tool to mark up your photo or
face to add a filter with your location
time or temperature swipe to the right
if you want to get really silly hold
down the screen when the front-facing
cameras on select one of these lenses
and hit record I look good and when
you're done adding the finishing touches
to that snap you're ready to add it to
your story or send it to a friend now
and it would explain to me what a Bay is
Oh Johanna it's just 2016 s version of
boo like your lovey